now soon covert will be behind us you're
thinking maybe it will be after omicron
but there'll be fewer and fewer states
with mandates or restrictions
and i know you can't wait for the old
normal to be back cheap gas affordable
airfare the freedom to move around
without masks without having to show
your vax card boost if you feel like it
don't if you don't
we're all looking forward to the end of
shaming and recriminations but
before you get all excited let me tell
you what the organized left has planned
for you
first an end to private vehicular travel
listen carefully to trudy harrison who
works for british prime minister boris
johnson
that we can design a transport system
that is fit
for the future and free of fossil fuels
which moves us away from the 20th
century thinking
centered around private vehicle
ownership and towards greater
flexibility with personal choice
ah the ccp would be so proud
greater flexibility she said with
personal choice
but whose choice is it exactly to go
carless not mine not yours
but decisions about how to restrict and
track your personal travel
are being made right now by global
bureaucrats
the trendy climate change thinking in
europe is already here and it's wrapped
in a public health emergency
it's just another attempt to force new
rules on you without your consent
now their ultimate goal
limiting your ability to travel with
convenience
when you want where you want
this would mean an end to private car
ownership as we've known it and loved it
for decades
think about it this way it's the image
of the middle class american dream
though a job to support your family
buying your own home
and your own car
that liberal elites have hated for a
long long time
now you've heard of gun buybacks right
well i wouldn't put they're doing a car
buyback
why not
because they'd prefer we all run around
on these
and crocs and maybe a sweaty hoodie
then we can all live like the urban
dwellers
who are happy to stay home during covid
ordering in growing herbs and little
pots on their little balconies playing
fortnite
now this government dependency mindset
existed before covet for sure
but now it's worse and team biden and
the democrats are hoping to exploit this
dependency that they've grown going into
2022 and later in 2024.
now some of you may be thinking that i'm
just too pessimistic here we're never
going to go the way of europe we're too
strong and independent
but after watching our flaccid public
response to some of these covet controls
i have to tell you i'm not that
confident
think about how many americans are
rushing out to buy electric cars because
they think electricity will be cheap and
even maybe free
tens of thousands of charging stations
across america how awesome is that
well it's pretty awesome
until you realize that democrats plan to
follow europe and make electricity far
more expensive here as well
now ideally they'd like to restrict its
supply
what's happening in europe right now is
terrifying
european union labor commissioner
nicholas schmidt on sunday warned that
there are already millions of people in
europe not able to heat their homes
sufficiently and this number could rise
further
and i have another question what happens
when the wind doesn't blow
bloomberg notes that low speeds have
reduced output and then they cite years
of lower investment in oil and gas
well
whose fault is that
europe is now finding itself unable to
affordably heat their homes all
self-inflicted wounds
the eurocrats just run things
you know and they're just they just
there's all twisted the french transport
minister actually bragged about
eliminating travel options for travelers
france got a lot of attention for
banning short haul flights in places
where you could take the train two and a
half hours should this be strengthened
we've developed quite a big network of
high-speed trains and when you have a
competition between the rail the
high-speed rail and the planes the rail
wins
now why should this be a government
decision because they don't like the
free market that's why now beware
anytime a democrat uses children to push
an unpopular unwise policy proposal and
just as with kovid school closures were
for the kids safety ditto for electric
school buses
every day more than 25 million children
and thousands of drivers ride to and
from school on diesel buses
breathing toxic fumes
making the switch from diesel to
electric
is about improving the health
and well-being of our children
of our future
no applause there now if that stupidity
doesn't scare you just remember who'll
be in charge of the biden harris ev plan
national climate advisor i'm jennifer
granholm i think i'm the good friend
she's referring to i am the secretary of
energy and this classy class a truck is
a kenworth
fuel cell vehicle that we are about to
ride in so
are you not excited we have a deal
a bipartisan infrastructure framework
deal we do and it's awesome it is it's
big and it's beautiful and it's bold
now i know what you're saying here these
are incredibly smart and talented people
and they're not alone now who knew a
former rhodes scholar could have such
foresight
the people who stand to benefit most
from owning an ev
are often rural residents who have the
longest distances to drive they burn the
most gas and now being from south bend
indiana does he actually not realize
that farmers often need to drive long
distances for which a battery is not
always practical
or maybe the farmer should all travel on
something a little more creative
cool
can you imagine joe on that contraption
by the way
he's busy reading scripts that other
people wrote for him including a recent
litany of things that you'll get if you
buy an ev after the so-called build
buildback better passes including a 4500
tax credit if the vehicle is assembled
domestically with union labor
another obvious payoff to the unions
which one of the smartest innovators on
the planet elon musk doesn't much like
he recommended that biden kill the bill
i would say
honestly i would just can this whole
bill don't pass it that's my
recommendation
but the billionaires at the world
economic forum in davos believe that
they do know best and they spoke openly
earlier this year about a wholesale
transformation that is necessary among
independent nations across the globe
2021 will be the critical year to
re-establish trust
in our ability to shape our common
future in collective and constructive
ways the recovery cannot be a mere
restart the reconstruction must be a
transformation capitalism that works for
everyone
but a true resetting of capitalism
requires smashing the united states and
also will mean that everyone's standard
of living here will necessarily go down
as prices for energy go up
that means wasting billions on things
like building ev charging stations
across five military installations
every year
now aside from being completely in over
his head biden openly revealed the goal
to fight climate change he wants to get
as many cars off the road as possible
we will take literally millions of
automobiles off the road
off the road saving tens of millions of
barrels of oil
dealing with cleaning up the air
this is not hyperbole this is a fact
these are facts
that's another fact joe let me be clear
i like tesla's a lot i love biking like
the bike lanes but i also like
traditional combustion engine vehicles
and driving wherever i choose the
government has no right to tell us what
to do on either front picking winners
and losers no way because they declare
another emergency no thanks the coming
lockdowns may look a lot different but
the effect will be the same
you have less freedom and a lower
standard of living all because the
government decrees it as such
we must never allow this to happen in
our country and joe manchin
he should hear from every concerned
voter in west virginia
vote for this build back better
boondoggle and your career in office is
over
politicians who are supporting this
climate agenda must be beaten at the
polls and beaten badly
we don't want to be california with
their rolling blackouts huge crime
spikes economic losses and shrinking
population
we will not be locked down again not by
a coveted emergency and not by a climate
emergency and that's the angle hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else